why is influence so important find out
on this episode of LED live
[Music]
exposing dark
Ness welcome everyone to LED live today
we're going to talk about influence but
before we get to that I just want to
take a moment to thank our donors and
our patrons you guys are the ones that
make it all possible so we kind of have
two you might say
parallel donation programs you can
donate through our website you can
donate through patreon those links I
think are in the description below so
make sure you check those out if you are
looking to help us out you can help us
out multitude to other ways one of which
is prayer we always want prayer for the
things that we're doing so thank you for
all those prayers and thank you for
those who are helping make this show
possible also we want to let you know
that we have digital downloads many of
the things that we talk about on this
show they are in documentaries that we
have made so little light has a history
of making documentaries over a period of
more than 10 years so if you check this
link out that's on your screen or
possibly in the description below you're
going to see all these documentaries
that we've made in particular the one
today would probably be closer to a
documentary called pseudology The Art of
line or a documentary called Selfie
which is on social media since we're
hitting on the General Media topics and
a little bit on social media so make
sure you check those out on Vimeo
also we like comments we like YouTube
comments really to be honest we like the
nice ones uh but we'll read the ones
that aren't so nice too and so we get to
as many as we can and answer as many
questions as we can that way of course
if you have questions you can always
reach out to us on social media or
through email as well
and last but not least we are trying to
get this content out to a variety of
platforms and so we have a lot of our
content in Spanish uh probably not as
much as English but there's only one guy
that does the Spanish so he's a little
bit behind and we have an international
Channel and so we encourage you that if
you're wanting to help out with
subtitling or voiceover or anything like
that reach out to us and help grow those
other areas of our ministry
so having said all that we're going to
talk about influence okay what's the
first thing that comes to your mind when
it comes to influence
social media okay why
because
it's influential
okay I second that you second that I SEC
well not the reason I mean yes the
reason as well but also because people
literally are called influencers on
social media this is true okay or Gene
yeah I agree with you third it yeah okay
well I um when I Was preparing for this
seminar I was giving uh about a month
ago I looked up the definition of
influence because I'm like I don't know
you know what does the dictionary say
about that what is it what is it how
does it read so I'm going to lean a
little bit closer so I can read it
because my eyes aren't as good as they
used to be it says the capacity to have
an effect on the character development
or behavior of someone or something or
the effect itself the influence of
Television violence that now it's using
that as an example like the influence of
Television violence so those are pretty
big areas of life when you think about
behavior when you think about character
when you think about development those
are all very important areas when it
comes to
human beings so
also I want to let you guys know that
there is
you might say a show that we did a
couple years ago that's in this same
vein it's called mesmerized have you
watched that
I probably have in the past but if you
haven't you should watch it yeah there's
one that Scotty let out on and it was
one of those shows I remember when we
did and it was like it was really good
it was really kind of eye-opening to see
all the pieces of the puzzle come
together so check out mesmerized in
addition to this program as well
okay influence so
there is Harvard has like a lot of
schools right uh one of the schools is
uh Kennedy School so this is like a
public policy school and they were
looking at a particular problem in the
world
in Mexico there was a high level of
violence and aggression towards women
and they thought how can we combat that
problem okay so as I was reading this
article it didn't take me long the very
first sentence jumped out at me just
huge and here's what it said media has
the power to influence individual
beliefs
attitudes and behaviors
just straight out of the gate that's
what they said and I said wow that's
that's a pretty bold statement to open
with and so you can you can tell they're
kind of tipping their hand like how are
we going to tackle the program
so what they did is they used a radio
program
and they developed you know this program
in Mexico and and put it on different
stations to combat this problem and
decrease aggression and violence towards
women it worked
and it worked because media does have
influence just like they recognize it
does have influence and power over
people's attitudes their behavior their
development their character all of that
and in addition to that I thought well
you know maybe that's kind of a one-off
but I came across this this Ted Talk too
pretty much said the same thing there
was a lady who she felt very passionate
about what's called an honor killing
she's from Pakistan and she's a
filmmaker
you ever heard of these honor killings
yeah okay so she made a film about
honored killings and we'll put the link
of this Ted Talk in the description
below on our killings
no no no against it oh okay so an honor
killing is when a male member of a
family will kill a girl or a woman
because they believe that that
individual has brought shame to the
family
and so that's that's basically what it
is and so it was it used to be legal to
just kill them in the name of honor and
that was it and there was no
repercussions for that at all like it
just gets off scot-free so this lady and
I'm not even going to try to pronounce
her name I'll sweatshirt for sure can I
ask a question about that real quick I
was I had kind of heard of this but I
thought it was more about the um the
idea that like in if any member of the
family converts to Christianity or
converts or dishonors the family in any
way they could be killed like for
instance if it was just a a mother in
the family and her son decided she
wanted to he wanted to convert to
Christianity isn't she according to that
religion maybe that way in in some
countries I I
don't know okay I wouldn't be able to
speak to that so you're not Islam or
Muslim no not and this is yes yeah
anyway so she made a film to combat this
problem and change people's uh you might
say hearts and Minds about it and her
film actually won an Oscar
and she took it back to Pakistan and got
the support of the governor and he or
the Prime Minister that's what it was as
a prime minister and he's like I will
screen your film and he publicly came
out against honor killings
well
that was all great but the next day one
happened
you know and then the next day after
that the next day after that and she
kind of realized we have to take this
thing on the road so they took they
built kind of like a mobile Cinema and
started taking it through the country
and they had one section even in this
truck for women where they had like
theater style seating so they could go
in away from the men so they wouldn't be
ashamed or anything like that and they
would view the film and other pieces of
um film that they had developed to
combat this ideology
they seen the power of that working in
Pakistan and they saw a pretty dramatic
change I mean the government passed a
law that said it was illegal
so it's pretty amazing how you can use
this kind of technology to change an
opinion to change a belief to change an
attitude wow
so
um you guys all have birthdays right
obvious question right I had one
recently and people on your birthday
they oftentimes like to ask you just
before that what do you want
right what do you tell them fairly
different every year
yeah probably I always thought you'd
never tell your wish or it won't come
true okay
I guess I never bought it
what do you think people ask you that
um so they know your secrets
Brittany
it's an open discussion I'm like trying
to facilitate discussion why do you
think people ask you that what do you
think of your birthday yeah
um because you're celebrating you so
it's like all about you
do you think that I mean at least as I
look at people are trying to please you
right there's nothing necessarily wrong
with that it's just they're trying to
make you happy right
oftentimes social media like you guys
mentioned before it asks a different
question and ask the question what do
you like
why do you think they asked that
question
they want to know what's in your head
why
because they don't know what's in your
head well that's true or they don't know
what's in your head it's actually the
fastest way for them to understand you
all right why is that important
statistics yeah so if you look at your
screen you're going to see some
screenshots from Tick Tock and you'll
notice that on Tick Tock they when you
sign up they say choose your interests
right you are selecting your interests
for them right it gives them the
information very quickly now they kind
of understand you and what do you think
that you're going to see
after you choose your interests my
interest yeah you're going to see your
interests right I mean absolutely I mean
you've helped them get very far very
quickly
uh you can skip that section but if you
notice at the top of the screen there's
a very small skip button I've circled
that in red why do you think the skip
button is small because they don't want
you to say they really don't want you to
skip it right and so it's small kind of
up there I mean Regina is all about ux
UI she she gets it so they do the same
thing on platforms like Pinterest you
know you sign up like what are you
interested in and then you're gonna see
more and more of what you're interested
in yeah and
that's all they really start feeding you
is when you everything you click on is
something that tells them they want more
of that and it creates what's called a
social validation feedback loop right is
is this also the same thing as cookies
like when you're on the internet and
they're like except these cookies and
that's how they track what you're
interested in I mean ties it to Facebook
dude track but that's not why this is
like it's two things that work together
but are are separate like them asking
you what your interests are
is is cookies yeah are probably helping
that but it's not it's a different why
they're asking cookies are the Box
Cookies have been around for a lot of
information and what he's talking about
is the information in the Box yeah
that's deep
so these are in the Box
no cookies are the Bucks cookies are the
Box
okay so I'm hungry I'm sure you are
okay okay okay okay
so
Pinterest you know they they do this
kind of thing all these different social
media websites are generally asking you
what you like because they want to
understand you now the reason they want
to understand you is because ultimately
they're all businesses right and
businesses exist for primarily one
reason and that's to what create money
yeah well make money and the government
creates money yes oh wait sorry that's
political joke
[Laughter]
anyway the longer they can keep you on
their platform the more money they can
make right I mean that just makes sense
so
but that means that their conflict of
interest runs pretty high right because
they just want to keep you on all the
time so there's no reason for them to
really do anything that would cause you
to disengage right so
just keep that in mind you would think
that after covid digital advertising may
have dropped off but it actually didn't
after covet it got even probably more
strong in 2021 there was a 189 billion
dollars worth of digital advertising
spend it's an incredible amount of money
right
and why are they spending 189 billion
dollars on digital ads different
companies well I think
when covet happened everything kind of
Switched more digitally anyway we became
heavily reliant on that sure and I don't
think it's changed after that sure it
probably hasn't changed yeah why spend
so much money
because they know it can influence the
way you think
okay and what you want and you're you're
exactly right and
um
another reason is because they're not
just putting that money in there
just to serve you an ad right they're
businesses they're putting that money in
there to get money back and so
if you look at the numbers you can see
that year by year
even though they spend their digital
advertising Revenue just keeps
increasing so in 2021
advertising revenue from social media
platforms from doing their digital
advertising spin was 50 billion dollars
that's what they made
so it's like this if I told you I'm
going to give you the choice whether or
not to make a 200 investment okay 200
bucks you put 200 bucks in you're gonna
get 250 bucks out
would you do it
yeah I would get 50 bucks I mean Brad
the only figure I mean it's not a trick
question of course you do I'd do it all
day long right here's two thousand
dollars right you'd be spending that
money like hotcakes if you knew that
money was come coming back to you every
time and that's essentially what they're
doing they know it works they know
they're making money off of it and so
they just keep spending the money
because the money keeps coming back and
they're making tons of money off of it
so basically what they're selling then
is your time or rather they are really
profiting from you
giving your time to them right so my
question for most people is what do you
get out of it um
right there's lots of things that you do
with your time
but when you spend your time on their
platform what kind of return are you
getting for that dopamine yeah I mean
essentially that's what it is right
dopamine you're not you're not generally
getting any kind of monetary return or
anything like that but here you know as
an average individual you would say my
time is worth something and yet here we
find ourselves giving our time away to
these different companies and saying yep
here's my time yeah I'm selling my time
for
ads to be served to me
so here
um here's something I found pretty
fascinating one thing we see in the
realm of media it's not just the way
that we use our time but also influence
right influence is the reason why China
and a number of other countries they
censor American content when it comes to
them because it doesn't align with their
values when it comes to Media so here's
an article from the LA Times not a small
newspaper not a Christian newspaper by
any means right
and they have an article about minions
minions about minions the Despicable Me
franchise okay
did you know that the latest Minions
movie was censored in China
why why that's a good question why do
you think it was censored do you have
any idea I mean maybe you probably
haven't seen it right Despicable Me yeah
I think I'd not the new one but I saw
like the first one that came out yeah
not that we're like promoting going
watching movies right right of course
you haven't seen
you're supposed to say yes I have not
seen it
okay yes I have not seen there we go
so
they made this observation in the
article kind of right out of here I
don't remember as the first sentence or
shortly thereafter they said the
Despicable Me franchise is known for
flipping the script on children's movies
by making the bad guys the heroes that's
like all movies and China had a problem
with that
you might yeah you would think yeah
that's in a lot of movies but they
noticed it specifically in this and of
course you know they recognized the
audience level that it's targeted at
it's young children and here they are
it's like the the bad guys are winning
and specifically what they had a problem
with there are no consequences
um
you know the bad guys just kind of get
away with everything at the end
and China's like wait no no no that
doesn't fly so they changed the movie
and the what they put out to their
audiences was
that bad guys do time
for crime
so how do they do that how do you change
a movie because that would require a
huge uh 3D setup and you know Pixar in
China it actually happens all the time
money is like do does China pay for that
yeah it actually happens all the time
and sometimes they do so for example
um
Iron Man 3 okay
Iron Man 3 there is a scene where Tony
Stark goes in to be operated on right
well for American audiences they see one
thing for Chinese audiences do you know
what they see
the doctor's Chinese they swap the
doctor out huh okay and it's actually a
very famous Chinese actor that plays the
part of the doctor
in one of the latest James Bond films
for example like Skyfall
so he is shown in the American version
right in the version most everybody sees
he's shown fighting against people who
have
uh they're Chinese and it shows him
winning
so they cut those scenes out for Chinese
audiences because they don't want
Chinese people to look weak and easily
defeated wow so that's there there's
actually multiple films and and for
different reasons like the movie Titanic
right let's probably before your time
and now I've seen it for your time
that's a popular movie okay yeah it was
a popular movie so Titanic there's a
scene where the lady Rose is shall we
say exposed okay that scene is cut now
they cut that for moral reasons they
don't right China's really big on like
no nudity and things like that so they
cut that right out but different things
are changed for different reasons for
example in
um
in the one I can't remember which one it
was it was another Marvel Avengers film
uh with the Manchurian
no no no the Mandarin not the Mandarin
the Mandarin the character that had a
mandarin he was a an enemy of Iron Man
so the Mandarin is in the comic books is
typically a Chinese character
Mandalorian not the Mandalorian the
Mandarin is Chinese I thought it was a
Chinese language right but the character
in the comic who's on first it's also a
first I'm so confused is Chinese okay in
the movie when they play the villain
against Tony Stark okay is is a white
guy oh okay so different things like
that are changed and sometimes like you
said China will pay for and what we're
starting to see is Chinese companies
investing or partnering in big Hollywood
studio films so that they can shape the
content
so
you know the irony I think in this is
that I'm
I kind of like China in that because
they are it seemed more moral than the
United States but I mean there's a
two-edged sword at that because then how
much force do you want in your country
right you know yeah and and I would say
that that I agree with you I don't think
necessarily the things that they are
censoring or doing are are always bad I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that especially
when it comes to the moral sensitivity
it's definitely uh uh more moral
sensitivity there I'm just pointing out
that it's important enough to an entire
government
to censor a film that not even everybody
in their country will see right
a few people will see it
but an entire government is like no we
do not want that influence here cut it
out
change the ending this does not fly in
our country fascinating so if it's
important to an entire country
what does that say to us as individuals
that make choices every day on what
comes into our minds and what doesn't
and when we tell ourselves it's just
entertainment exactly because to the
Chinese government apparently it's not
now like you said it's a two-edged sword
right so interesting article
I think this was done in uh well let me
look actually yeah 2020. the FBI
released a statement in 2020. about
China's attempt to influence U.S
institutions
so and they they had a variety of
methods it wasn't just social media or
anything like that they were they were
complaining about their influence at
universities and and different things
and so here the FBI is saying whoa let's
let's take a step back we representing
the American government and American
people we have concerns as a law
enforcement agency about the influence
that China is having on our country
so so clearly governments are concerned
about other people and their influence
in the country right they think it's a
big deal enough enough of a big deal to
squawk about it so this this statement
that the FBI released the word influence
was used 16 times
and it wasn't just like a you know it's
in the title and the heading kind of
thing you know it was like they said
influence over and over and over again
because they're a little concerned that
China is getting too much influence on
our country and why is that well
in the United States we have a generally
it's described as a capitalistic
Republic Democratic Society right and
that China is more the other socialist
you know they're they're Communists and
so the US is saying we don't want that
here you know we're concerned about
those values anyway that sir that sword
works both ways in in entire governments
are concerned about who's influencing
who and that's that's really the whole
point of that wait I have a question
yeah um them saying influence in the
article 16 times is that like
um supposed to be a subconscious thing
so that when you think of about China
you think of influence like no I think
they're just trying to draw a they're
using that word multiple times because
it's important so an example of like
example of that is if Jesus says
something like three times right right
it's paid special attention he's yeah
because he's repeating it we should pay
attention to it and so in that article
they're they're not just using it once
they're saying it multiple times so we
should pay attention yeah it's
reinforcement got it
so have you ever heard of this man
Robert and I probably butcher's name
cialdini he's Italian I think he's a
psychological PhD type wrote a book
called influence back in 1984.
um he
said some things in this book that I
think are really interesting and really
describe how people behave
so one of the quotes from his book reads
this way we use the actions of others to
decide on proper behavior for ourselves
a pretty broad statement what do you
think of that
we use the actions of others
yeah to decide on proper behavior first
decide on proper behavior I think that's
true I think all we are is made up of
learned behavior when we're young we're
mimicking our parents we are influenced
by our friends our environment I think
that's true
and that's not necessarily
good or bad
right it could be both depending on
those environmental variables right when
it comes to things like social media if
you see a lot of likes or views on
something
you're almost compelled to view it
because other people have right that's
where that environmental component comes
in that you are talking about
on the flip side if you're the one
posting then
that becomes tricky because it starts to
Define your self-worth and we've seen
this from studies for things like
Instagram where you know people have
they'll take the same picture to two
different audiences and they will
they have a way of inflating because
it's just a photoshopped image they'll
take one and they'll give it lots of
likes and they'll give another one like
very few likes and even though it's the
same picture which one do you think
people click on the one with the lights
alike so it gets a lot more likes
because it already has likes on it so
um how do you or what do you think about
like now Instagram has this thing where
you can actually hide all your likes so
now it's like
this person plus others it no longer
shows the number I think that's healthy
well on Facebook and someone clicks like
on some comment I made you know I go
back and read what comment did I say
that someone liked you know I mean it's
I think it's natural to want to be
natural to know what people enjoy but
also they want to know what other people
enjoy too and by that we learn and I
think that's in and of itself a danger
yeah it's really exploiting you know
some some parts of human psychology as
what it is so
I like the way that the Bible says it
though because we live in this world and
there's all kinds of things that have an
opportunity to influence us whether it's
from social media or environmental
factors or what have you we have all
these influences but the Bible says and
do not be conformed to this world
right but be transformed by the renewing
of your mind that you may prove what is
that good and acceptable and perfect
will of God really
you know we should be discovering what
God's will is
and not be so concerned or not be
subjecting ourselves maybe even to so
much of the world's influence because
that can lead us astray if we're not
careful
well uh chaldini also said a few other
things that I thought were interesting
he said this in the process of examining
the reactions of other people to resolve
our uncertainty however we are likely to
overlook a subtle but important fact
those people are probably examining the
social evidence too yeah
it's very interesting right we
oftentimes look at what other people are
doing and think oh because they're doing
it they have it all figured out
but they don't right they're just
figuring out just like you are but
because there's numbers
we oftentimes do the proverbial you know
if your friends are jumping off a bridge
would you do the same thing did your
parents ever say that to you yeah yeah
they did how about yours yeah of course
yeah everybody uses that right this also
reminds me of I can't remember which led
live this was but there was one that was
done like maybe a year ago where there
was that experiment where there was like
um like the smoke detector was there was
a group of people in the room and a
super detector was going off and it was
like waiting to see like there was
everybody was in on and except one
person I think that was in mesmerized
wasn't it I I forget but it was less
than a year ago to get mine a bit it was
more than a year ago yeah more more
because I was mesmerized was but maybe
maybe we used it again yeah
it was yeah and so they were just trying
to see who would actually get up and do
something and what they found was that
most people if they even though like the
building is on fire and you know the
smoke alarm is going off they will stay
seated with everyone else around them
wow and it also reminds me when like
whenever like I'm scared of like I have
fears of like underground subway trains
and stuff okay and I was always advised
like you know that you're okay if you
just look at all the people around you
if they're calm then you're good and so
it's like
[Laughter]
okay
everybody be calm for Brittany right
all right well the Bible also says this
um I think this is a is a great thing
for young people especially to keep in
mind it says let no one despise your
youth but be an example to Believers in
word in conduct and love and spirit and
faith and impurity and there's a whole
lot wrapped up in there that we don't
necessarily have time to go and flesh
out on this show but
when you're young you can learn to stand
you can learn to be an example you can
learn to weather the influences that are
around you and that's really the Bible's
challenge to any young person right that
you've learned to stand for yourself
learn to be your own person and not just
be influenced by the world
so cialdini had some principles that he
laid out in something he called social
proof is a theory that he developed and
he used these to describe how people
behave now I think I was seeing that
there's like seven of them now I'm only
gonna go over four
but four four ways that people behave
okay one of the things that people take
into consideration is uncertainty when
you are uncertain about any given
situation and what to do
do you know what people normally do when
they're uncertain
Google it they do what other people
around them are doing ah right
so if you're unsure
just like you were talking about on the
subway right right you looked at
everybody else and like oh if they're
calm then I should be calm because you
were uncertain on whether you should be
anxious or not okay so that's that's the
uncertainty principle
another principle is similarity so for
example if Brad and I are in a crowd and
we were wearing the same clothes and had
the same hairstyle and all these kind of
factors
um I might make my decisions based on
the people that were most like me okay
similarity it could be your ethnicity it
could be your gender it could be all
kinds of things but we look at other
people around us look for similarities
and then we say okay well if they're
doing that and I'm like them in these
ways then that's probably what I should
do it's like the elevator idea that's
new to elevator everyone's facing you
you're going to turn around right right
right
so similarity
another one is expertise
so you know the popular example is on TV
commercial you see this expert and it's
like you know I'm a doctor so and so and
you should take this medication Zoloft
or whatever because it's the number one
doctor recommended you know you know how
it goes and so people look at that like
oh well the doctor recommended it so I
should you know I should do that and
that that's that's a double-edged sword
I'm not necessarily saying there's
anything wrong with listening to people
who are experts in their field they
more than more than likely know more
about the subject than you do you know
on that topic just as a side note not to
go down this too far but it's
interesting that that doctor recommended
thing
actually they get the statistics from
this by handing the doctor a bunch of
free items from that from that uh thing
and then go to the doctor later say hey
what do you give out to your patients
what do you recommend well I recommend
yeah this one well obviously because he
has a bunch of free samples free samples
yeah and so you see that four out of
five doctors recommend the free samples
that they gave out yeah they did so what
if they only gave
the samples of five doctors yeah and
then four only four recommended you
would never know right or as I like to
say nine out of ten people will disagree
that one person will or nine out of ten
people agree that one person will always
disagree right
yeah yeah lame joke anyway
um number is also another factor in
chaldini's Social proof uh Theory and he
basically said if there's a lot of
people doing it then you're more likely
to do it too you know the if everybody's
jumping off the bridge kind of scenario
so
I look at all those and I say do you
know where all those come to play in
there's actually a Bible story where all
those come into play and that's with
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego right
um would they be influenced by the world
would they be influenced by the
prevailing culture of the day or would
they stand for God and I think that test
is coming to God's people again right
they had and they they could have had I
don't think they did but I think
when you look at that story you know the
really the focus is on those three but
those were not the only ones taken
captive from Jerusalem to Babylon right
they were
other Jews that were there I think those
Jews fell into this uncertainty
principle right they're like what do we
do like we're in Babylon and like
everybody else is doing this thing like
I guess we should just bow down well
also what it meant if you didn't bow
down well yeah I mean there there was a
there was a threat for sure heavy threat
um
so that that certainly didn't help but
then there's this similarity right
those other Jews were probably attending
Babylon you you know and looking at all
the other Babylonian students
and we're like man everybody else from
the university is just you know is
bowing down I guess I should do that too
you also have the the part about
um
not just similarity but number there's a
lot of people there A lot of people
doing the same thing you also have
expertise so all the government
officials it says in that that chapter
of the Bible is Daniel chapter three all
the government officials are up there
right and what are they doing they're
the ones that tell everybody what to do
that's what they're doing too they're
bowing down just like everybody else and
so you can see how all those factors can
play into a scenario and I think that is
what will happen at the end of time
people are going to be uncertain about
what to do everybody's going to be doing
the same thing you're going to look
around you and find similar people just
following the crowd
and you're you're going to find it
yourselves uh with all these experts I
think religious experts and scientific
experts and experts in all these fields
are going to be telling people this is
what we have to do
in the end of time you know I think it's
interesting because the Bible says
Revelation says that they'll accept it
with the with the hand or on the
forehead and the hand is what you do
exactly and the forehead is is much
heartedly what you think
so I think it's interesting so yeah for
sure
so Revelation 13 parallels that scenario
and so I think that's why we have to be
careful about what influences us what we
choose to influence us and why we need
to learn to stand for ourselves
uh one more thing I thought was
interesting the San Diego State did an
interview recently with a psychologist
and her name was Dr Gene twinge and she
comments on how technology is having an
influence on young people right so
here's what she said among teens many
users of social media that is
um about five plus hours a day
are twice as likely to be depressed as
non-users
Facebook's own research found that using
Instagram led to body image issues we
talked about that earlier for many teen
girls
screen time in general like TV gaming
texting is also linked to depression but
not as strongly so yeah TV can can
inhibit it can lead to depression gaming
can lead to depression texting can lead
to depression but lots more than that is
social media
so
that's that's part of its influence now
she said she continued to say in this
article depression rates begin to
increase after an hour of social media
use a day
but the Cure is usually more sh
allow sorry about the curve but the
curve is usually more shallow for other
types of screen time with higher
depression rates only appearing after
three or four hours
a day of use so two hours a day of
social media use seems to be different
from two hours a day of TV watching for
example
so not all screen time is necessarily
equal but it seems like social media
time which is probably one of the most
influential
um of all platforms can can really lead
to depression so when I think about that
I was doing some research on this and I
wondered what type of content are people
largely consuming on these different
social media platforms what do you think
it is
video okay video so think more genre oh
memes okay memes genre
music okay music she's got two answers
that's fine
Regine do you have any idea
movies okay Brad
I have no idea I really don't you can
take one of my answers okay I'll take
over I found this really really
surprising
but it makes perfect sense
so they're depressed and the top type of
content they're consuming
is comedy huh
memes yeah essentially like memes funny
stuff right right why because
essentially they're self-medicating
right right if you're depressed that's a
pick-me-up from that and it helps keep
you going even though you're kind of
cycling into that over and over again so
you're looking for a pick-me-up on a
regular basis to get you out of that
depressive cycle
so
um yeah and it's interesting but it's
also really really sad to see that
you know the the type of content they're
going to on the platforms isn't helping
them you know they spend more and more
time on the platform they get more and
more depressed even though the type of
content they're supposed to be getting
is a pick-me-up so it's it's pretty
pretty sad I think what's also sad too
is that because social media is so
ingrained in our society like if
someone's an alcoholic you won't just
leave them to be an alcoholic you know
there are steps and things to do about
it but I think people are still trying
to discover
you know how to manage social media but
then it's also hard because then you
have so many advertisers on there who do
want money so they don't actually want
anybody to get off so how do you do that
that's that's why I mentioned that
conflict of interest yeah earlier
um they're they're interested in lining
their pocketbooks not necessarily
helping other people and there's all
kinds of disturbing signs like one of
the things we talk about in our social
media documentary is the fact that
a lot of these Tech CEOs they send their
kids to schools that don't use
technology at least not for grades one
through eight yeah like an example that
is a Waldorf School in California
they don't use technology for one
through eight now once you get into High
School they'll start to use some
technology but not in the early
development because they think it
inhibits human interaction
um yeah there's some there's some other
things but I encourage you guys to check
out that documentary selfie and you'll
you'll find a lot of interesting
information there
but just kind of bringing this thing to
a close kind of wrapping it up
the Bible tells us in Proverbs 12 26 the
righteous should choose his friends
carefully
for The Way of the Wicked leads them
astray and I want to
just expand on that a little bit
not just your friends carefully but also
your content your influence because
those friends
the way this text is written those
friends are influencing that person in
the way that they are going to go for
their future and the choices that
they're going to make
and in today's world we spend less time
with people less time with friends and
more time with content and so I think as
a principle this applies the righteous
should choose not just his friends but
his content carefully because the Way of
the Wicked Will Lead You astray right so
if you're consuming wickedness it's
going to take you on a bad path and then
the other scripture I thought was was
good in this case was do not be deceived
evil company corrupts good habits
awake to righteousness and do not sin
for some do not have the knowledge of
God I speak this to your shame so
um
obviously it's it's only helpful to us
each one of us to have good habits and
what is that good habits what are those
good habits lead to it leads to
righteousness right which is what we
should all be seeking after right that's
that's Christ wants to give us his
righteousness because we don't have it
of ourselves and that righteousness
is is is where we're headed you can look
at the Bible from beginning to end what
I think is fascinating is in the
beginning there are certain things that
happened
and if you look at the way the book ends
God is trying to restore those things in
the end in the beginning there was no
sin
in the end God is going to eradicate sin
it will be no more so in between time it
only makes sense that we would be
embracing
Christ working in our lives in a way
that
eliminates those things from our lives
you know just because we we can
experience more of Heaven here and now
if we Embrace that right if we Embrace
Christ's righteousness it's not because
we can do anything it's not because I'm
going to work my way to heaven it's not
because of any of that it's what it's
what God actually wants to give me and
that's a beautiful thing
in the Bible is just encouraging us that
you know what those that influence you
affect that and you are only
damaging your experience here and now
and it can be so much better
and so I think God is really inviting us
to a a better experience a better life
and that's why we need to be careful
about what influences us so again I just
want to encourage all of you
check out this video mesmerized uh it's
probably more exciting than this video
there's a lot of really neat video clips
in there and it really kind of helps
drive this point home
this is more informational I guess
that's kind of my style I love the video
clips I wish I would have found them but
that's a good video and that's why
there's a variety of us here on LED live
we commit all kinds of information from
different angles to help you guys out
and so unless you guys have any other
questions or have any other final
comments we're going to wrap this up and
let everybody out I think I have one
okay so we're talking we've talked about
influence and now we're aware of
influence so let's say someone is aware
of these things and they say well you
know what now I'm aware of it
I can continue consuming because now
it's no longer subconscious or
subliminal like I'm totally aware of it
you get what I'm saying yeah I totally
get what you're saying the Bible text
that we just read addressed that
so
you know if we go back to this one here
it says the righteous should choose his
friends carefully
for the way the wicked leads demonstrate
it doesn't say
you know if you continue with your bad
friends it'll be all right
right it says no no choose your friends
carefully right like don't don't go back
to those other things or don't think
that if you're if you know the
difference between good friends and bad
friends that the bad friends aren't
going to influence you
it's essentially saying the opposite of
that it says no they go into influence
you whether you know it and or believe
it it's gonna happen so so what about
this
um question for everyone
what if you or you or you make a a quick
mini documentary about this and you use
it to expose something you use it to
show the dangers in a certain music or
movie and you get people that say this
and this is what people have said that
you are by showing this
you are you are doing exactly opposite
what you're saying in other words
in other words if you show the bad then
you are promoting the bad
what do you think about that
I don't think that's true because I
think that exposing and promoting are
two different things
and for a lot of people you can't really
like if you don't expose it they won't
know and I think also where the where
what what you're showing what is it
centered on you know like I know when we
do expose we're telling them like these
things are bad for your spiritual health
for you know your relationship with
Christ and all these things we're
leading them to Jesus at the end of it
we're not just saying yeah guys just
totally go watch this and it's so cool
and stuff like that so
yeah I was going to look up a scripture
from Ephesians chapter five eleven
expose the works and have no fellowship
with the work with the unfruitful works
of darkness but rather expose them
Paul is not saying participate
continually in those things you know
he's saying those things need to be
brought to light for what they are
um
so I totally get where people are coming
from I totally understand that and some
people
do not
they just don't see it and I think for
myself
I don't think I would have necessarily
stopped just because there's
there was a difference between somebody
telling me
actually it wasn't even somebody telling
me I knew
the things that I was consuming was
wrong but it didn't
click right and so when I finally had
somebody show me like a side-by-side
comparison that's essentially what it
was a side-by-side comparison and was
like oh now the light bulb went on it
was like that's why I don't want that
[Music]
um
there's a blinding that happens to
individuals I think you know where
they're they're you know it's it's like
this Veil that's over your eyes and you
you just can't see it you don't get it
and
um I think this is one one method that
God is using to help open people's eyes
and we've had countless people tell us
the same thing you know if I had not
seen that material I don't think I could
have
broken away for it like I see it for
what it is now and now I can completely
walk away and it's funny because people
there are many people are very familiar
with our ministry and our material and
then what they tell us is like oh yeah
but I don't I haven't watched it for
years I don't I don't I don't watch that
stuff anymore I don't I don't I don't
even watch your content and they have no
idea that like we have a YouTube channel
or anything because they've completely
steered the direction of their life and
they have different viewing habits a
different walk with God and they realize
oh yeah I don't I don't need those
things I don't want those things anymore
for them it clicked
is it the right method for everybody
probably not I don't I don't think it
necessarily works for everybody
different people are worse worked in a
variety of ways just like on this
program there are different people we
know this because they write in and tell
us different people identify with Brad
or identify with Brittany or Mikey or
Scotty or myself it's it takes a variety
of people I think to
preach or speak messages of truth
because they speak to different
individuals in a different way and
that's
only thing I can say is that's the Holy
Spirit you know working through those
different people on different hearts and
Minds so I hear what they're saying
um
I have the the I guess I'm on this side
of it seeing the fruit in my life and
the fruit in others people's lives and
so
um
it's not our joy
to just
look at Darkness
right it's not what we're trying to do
here
so
yeah or promote Darkness at least it's
not it's not I mean I can say that for
myself and I think everybody else here
is the same way we're not just trying to
promote Darkness
it's a call it's a call to turn
so
yeah well thank you all for watching
this episode of LED live we hope that
you have appreciated that information
and we hope that you will share it with
somebody else who needs to hear that and
maybe needs to make some changes in
their own lives or even solidify a
decision in their life and so thank you
for watching thank you for donating make
sure you check out our cool shirts and
hoodies like the one I'm wearing and
what Brad's wearing you can get those on
lightwear.shop and we hope that you will
have an excellent rest of your day and a
good weekend take care and we will see
you next time
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]